at the end of last year I shot a series
of videos with a company called maths
pathway and the videos are basically an
interview series with me about my
teaching philosophy and also some of the
ideas and practices that I bring into my
classroom when I'm teaching mathematics
the videos are focused on teachers which
is not the main audience of this channel
I know but I realize that many people
who are watching our educators so if you
are interested in the way that I teach
and why I teach that way then head over
to my second channel where I'm going to
be uploading all of the videos but I
thought I'd include one here just so you
can get a sense of what they're all
about
enjoy guys hi I'm Annie woo and I'm a
mathematics teacher I want you to
picture a world where people hate they
loathe learning music because everyone
is forced to learn music and they have
to memorize all these notes they have to
become very good at coloring in the
little notation to try to communicate a
piece to someone they have to memorize
all of these pieces and they are tested
on how quickly they can regurgitate
those pieces and if you can do it
accurately and not miss a note and have
all the right things there then we'll
give you an A and we'll say you know
very good your excellent maybe if you
keep this up for 10 years you might
actually get to hold a musical
instrument or write your own piece once
upon a time if you if you can you know
survive for that long can you imagine a
world where people fall about music that
way rather than is a creative expression
of the human soul that we used to to
articulate the way we feel about the
things and understand and articulate our
experience of the world that'd be a
really sad world to live in but that is
the world we live in right now because
that's the way people view mathematics
they view it as something they're forced
to do that don't enjoy they don't view
it as creative or imaginative at all but
it's only if people survive you know all
of this mandatory schooling that it
might actually get to say University and
experience mathematics is something that
they can they can invent for themselves
and experience in a way that helps them
articulate their understanding of the
world and it can just make up rules and
play I want the world that our children
grow up in to be one where they realize
mathematics is a deeply human thing it's
it's a sense
we all have and some people have sharper
senses than others I have terrible
eyesight but that doesn't mean I don't
think of seeing as something that's
integral to Who I am as a human being I
want everyone to think of mathematics as
it's deeply natural to them as speaking
that the language that comes out of
their mouths when they're when they're
just a toddler I think that mathematics
has the power to help people see and
appreciate things around them that would
be invisible otherwise and I want them
to have access to that and earn that for
themselves
[Music]